all these platforms become all kinds of
content they start up you know what
Instagram started office photography
nerds yeah yeah yeah true [ __ ]
sunsets with a [ __ ] filter Facebook
was College talk hooking up you know
Twitter was tech nerds they all started
something and they all evolved to
everything you got your good morning on
this beautiful Tuesday in March last day
of March smarts 31st it has been an
interesting month for so many of us this
is tea with Gary B I am your host Gary
Vaynerchuk I am humbled this has been an
incredible series two hours of Q&A we're
going deep we're going deepest [ __ ]
let's get into the first question this
[Music]
episode good morning good morning Rashad
how are you good good how are you Gary
thanks for having me yeah of course
where you from from Austin right now and
very very excited to be here
Thank You Freya yeah I have a let me a
bit a little quick background by myself
it has been a journey I was born and
raised in Iran and I graduated from high
school in Westchester Pennsylvania went
back for college back to Iran got my
associate degree in architecture over
there and then long story short right
now I'm a real estate agent here in
Austin and I guess the the question that
I have for you is more of a mindset kind
of a question so there has been multiple
times in my life that I've reached my
short-term goals and and after that you
know like I start feeling like
accomplished and feeling good about
myself and you know I mean so so I mean
how do you manage to don't stop keep
going in
and just grinding make a macro goal well
you know I mean like the bigger okay
yeah I mean you know for me I want to be
the greatest entrepreneur of all time
and that comes in the form in my opinion
of not only building successful
businesses but giving back to the most
people in the entrepreneurial game and I
want to buy the New York Jets
professionally and and those are my
professional kind of goals outside of
Who I am as a human and so I think you
need to make bigger goals because
there's a Hewett you there's a huge
letdown I made a video already that says
today's the worst day of my life and
it's the video i'm gonna play when i buy
the New York Jets there's a letdown if
you love the process and I think you
love the process and I think when you
achieve that goal there's always an
inherent letdown when I go on vacation I
look forward to it for so long that when
I get there on day one I'm actually more
upset because it was more fun the weeks
before getting pumped for it than the
actual event
right so you know and I may share that
DNA I think you need to make much bigger
[ __ ] goals I to be honest with you
whatever I have in my mind I just know
I'm gonna achieve it I know I'm gonna be
there cuz I'm very hard go go big big
big make yourself uncomfortable you
might be making yourself too comfortable
you might like the idea of achieving
goals more than actually achieving goals
do you see where I'm going you may like
you know like little goals that are
achievable you might be subconsciously
trying to portray that you can make [ __ ]
happen by keeping [ __ ] small you might
have so much more in you you see where
I'm going yeah and by the way one of the
reasons you may be upset is you might
actually realize that you're making
small goals it may look good to
everybody else but you somehow deeps
inside know that you've got so much more
in you you need to make bigger [ __ ]
goals grow I see where you're going I
see where you're going because so I'm
like I've been listening to you and I
like the idea of going slow and actually
yeah
build-it so when I first started for the
for the first months nothing happened
right now before this whole Cove in I
think happened I ended up like closing
I'm just doing leasing right now I don't
do bigger deals because I'm just
starting so I was yeah I was I was
leasing like three to four homes every
week and I've been to this town for not
even a year and and it's just like you
know and I'm I'm feeling like hey
whatever goals broke your your goal
we're talking real estate now homes yeah
your goal should be the number one real
estate agent in New York City not even
enough that it's not [ __ ] Austin Austin
small it's a beautiful by the way I love
Austin it's epic and by the way that's
exactly right notice the difference
between where we're at like you're like
hey I'm gonna be like a top player in
Austin and I'm like that's cool
but like what about being the number one
agent in New York City right now all the
sudden you got a big goal now on the
sudden right now you just [ __ ]
renting in Austin you're seven years
you're 12 years away from being number
one in New York that's what makes a fun
slow big you know you're not gonna cheat
it tomorrow and then be sad the next day
kind of goal you need a framework play
thank you
hi welcome see it thank you yeah I do
thank you I know I can see you see me
we're off to a good [ __ ] start here
on tea with Gary Vee I'm fired up with
that that was some real advice something
that's probably gonna help a ton of you
this morning
I appreciate Maria Jenna bebe Rock Dance
Theatre thank you so much dr. Clinton
bany
the chiropractor you're getting a follow
I'm your 85th follower Clinton beanie
that's what happens when you share this
show on Twitter Kacey Langley boom a
little like for you a little follow
I'm your 678 and I'm retweeting you
Casey so you're gonna get some new love
t-turn t tired Devin Alexander always
here with us dr. cha Kareem always here
was us Abbi Galvez you get a little like
you get a follow I'm your 75th follower
there
and Tom is in the building with a beanie
nonetheless I love how are you - how you
doing tom
I'm doing okay man how you doing Gary
really well actually good I want to
shout out your team Gary Vee and Dustin
man they do an awesome job thank you
thank you
they're fantastic so good to talk to you
background I've got 22 years background
in live theater guerrilla theater
independent theater as an actor and
director ran one company for 13 years
ran a mixed-use art venue for three
years I got nine novels published with
Random House and Simon & Schuster
that was cool yeah I got to write for
the comic book spawned a few years ago
for a few issues that wasn't cool oh
wait for it wait for it and then I've
gotten write some scripts for app video
games like phone games and stuff like
that really cool just finished shooting
my first short film a couple months ago
that was good time had a great time one
of the problems I'm having though I've
been I read your books watched videos
all this stuff and everything resonates
really deeper with me I'm trying to tell
all my writer friends like you got to
watch Gary B it's gonna totally change
everything the issue I'm having though
is translating everything I hear you
teaching everything and doing on tea
time to a sort of strictly entertainment
based business because the margins are
slim as [ __ ] you know and I'm sure
you've probably encountered this too
with with your writing like people here
Oh Random House or spawn or like you can
just walk in and get a job with whoever
like no it doesn't work that way dude it
does not work that way so no I need like
I mean like a thousand followers to pay
me two bucks a month and I'm good yeah
that's it is that your thinking yeah
that's really it I got good news we're
gonna go right into this literally
during the first 45 seconds of this I'm
like [ __ ] should I hire this guy you're
clearly wildly creative where do you
live Phoenix Phoenix so let's play it
out no just kind of you know I'm you
know this I'm not the biggest fan of
subscription or content based businesses
but I'm a huge fan of access so when I
actually hear a thousand people paying
you two bucks a month right because
you're like dude I need to
dollars a month right is that what he
said yeah dude
writing for spawn having books published
what kind of books were they they were
the ones that they were traditionally
published where a young adult and before
dude you're on you're a very yeah you're
uric a couple things run through mine
I'm pretty pumped right now I think I'm
gonna [ __ ] scene to life right here on
the spot I'm not I'm kidding do a couple
things one that level of ability to
write in a world where so many people
want to be writers I think that you
should create a business where once a
week you send a detailed curriculum you
know you clearly can write that out and
and two times a month there's tea with
Tom or there's you know a two-hour
closed live stream right assume a closed
zoom where or whatever holds a thousand
people I don't know if there's even
close a thousand but I think that you
can easily just on what I just heard
easily create a $5 a month business you
charge people five dollars a month for
for a weekly email and a biweekly live
closed two-hour session pure QA
with the pure agenda of helping people
become better writers yeah okay so let's
number two number two immediately
starting yesterday I want you to go to
your best illustrator design friend
which you clearly have made through
these years and I want you to create
your Star Wars now let's explain let me
explain what I mean by that I want you
to go to the well in your head and I
want you to create three to four
characters and a make-believe land and I
want you to create an Instagram account
around this land what I want ultimately
is for you to sell 35 to 70 dollar
hoodies with these characters on them
but God for
bid it takes off miraculously on
Instagram or tick-tock it could lead to
some I you know this IP is where the
money is and what you do yes for sure so
you need to take the leap and actually
create the get along game create you
know you Star Wars is the apex you
create when I hear how awesome you are
where your ambitions financially are so
low because you love what you do so much
I'm like [ __ ] this is a layup this guy's
probably what's your I'm gonna I'm gonna
presale five dollars a month for you
right now literally right now what is
your email what is your email
Tom Tom wake up great even better like
no joke okay I just wanted to because
you're probably about to get 40 to 500
emails okay so Tom Dustin can people see
Tom Levine's name in the bottom left
hand corner like I can see it yeah they
can see it and I'm also looking on
LinkedIn and the feedback looks really
positive there you me in the comments
yeah like they're really into this yeah
because Tom's very sweet and has good
vibes purely let me just say this very
listen I've been doing this a long time
I don't do this up and Tom's got too
many w's on his board you know like you
just don't get to write for [ __ ]
spawn you just don't you just don't get
to like like you just don't get to you
don't get to write nine books that are
published by real publishers even if
they didn't sell for [ __ ] and I mean
that time like you know obviously you
know maybe they did sell maybe they did
it but it really is completely
irrelevant like getting to that point
you know you know it's very clear to me
that you're a creative fellow and I
really do believe that there's a ton of
people that can benefit from a
well-thought-out email or you know plans
ideas Tom basically actually let me ask
couple questions do you think that you
can that you can send 52 emails a year
that you have 52 thoughts ideas
strategies like you know inspirations
and if it was something you really focus
on do you think you can help people
become better writers yeah I do that
already so not to that yes yes yes and
you like the idea of spending two hours
every two weeks on live with thousand
people on the yes good okay okay you can
do anything
okay so I totally agree I think that's
great I did it a little bit before it
maybe a little bit as the problem I've
tried something similar to that and it
didn't work so now how let's talk let's
talk what do I do it so last year well
first of all I'm probably just gave you
a hundred customers and it's that you
probably have a hundred customers be
five by the time I hang up with you so
that might be you might have just needed
a little bit of a starting point but let
me know you don't [ __ ] it up good so
listening to you over the last few years
like I did I was doing a weekly first it
was a Facebook live and then a YouTube
live where it was just talking different
people doing some writing stuff like
that some coaching and whatever else I
really enjoy teaching writing it's a lot
of fun and one of the things that
regardless of whatever the class is
about that I always tell people is like
as soon as you decide someone should pay
you for writing fiction you just started
a small business and nobody's telling
writers that nobody is telling him that
at all it pisses me off
good yes I've already kind of been doing
that but it's you know we're talking six
seven ten fifteen viewers tuning into
that so clearly I'm doing something
wrong I assume I'm doing something wrong
to get that sort of viewership up in the
first place
you might be a great writer and a great
creative and a great teacher and you
just might not be a great marketer and
that's okay yeah right right like like
you know to me when you were done with
that live did you post produce it and
take all the questions and thoughts and
make eighty-three or nine or fourteen
piece of content and put that on
Instagram and things that nature have
you taken a hundred dollars and learn
how to run ads on Facebook and Instagram
right well no right so like have you run
pre-roll YouTube where you pop up and
say hey I've got you know there's like
so many theaters like again in the same
way that if I mean God if God forbid I
was creative enough to create spawn like
McFarlane or to be able to write I
probably have Hunger Games I'd probably
have spawn on my resume already because
I know how I made myself a superhero let
alone yeah I'm [ __ ] businessman you
know what I mean like I really know I
know that part so a couple things it's
irrelevant because I'm telling you right
now Tom at Tom led EE and calm like
you're about to have 400 emails and
in box actually I need you to tweet me
in an hour and tell me how many people
pick you up so it's Tom at Tom and calm
I think your business is 5 bucks a month
not to its a month which is [ __ ]
nothing it's nothing no nothing it's $60
a year the amount of people that want to
be writers that are watching right now
that pay 60 bucks for two books that
bring them no value here is a ton yeah
do you know what platform you're gonna
use to charge five bucks a month and
like how to put it behind a closed
livestream and things of that nature if
you don't and I can see your crime in
your mind if somebody knows what
platform Tom should use to create a
closed community that charges I haven't
monetizing the audience but I'm sure
there's a ton of smart things whether in
Squarespace whether WordPress whether in
something else that I don't know so
please hit up Tom in the title if you
hit up Tom with that say Tom I know how
to help you monetize Tom literally
fifteen people from my community right
now I'm gonna email you at Tom at Tom
Ellie ven comm they're gonna tell you
what platforms to use you're gonna set
that up today you're gonna put your bank
account there you're gonna name it
Tom's writing course whatever you decide
you're then gonna email back all 100 to
500 people that have just emailed you at
Tom at Tom ven calm and you're gonna say
yo I'm so flat probably you should
probably reply to them first as soon as
you hang up and be like I'm so flattered
I'll get back to you 24 hours you set it
up you send them the email and you know
80% of the people that email you because
some people back out between their hype
right now and tomorrow
80% of those people are gonna sign up
and you're gonna have a base and then
you're gonna take this recording once I
put on YouTube learn how to splice it
out and then take this and then start
posting this video cuz this is your
sales pitch and now you froze for me and
I love how you throw is you're like
looking up in the air Dustin did he
freeze for you too
yeah okay Zach yeah all right Tom you're
back I'm back that's it bro that's five
bucks a month five bucks a month once a
week
email very detailed maybe maybe I
recommend maybe giving them five links
like I want you to put work in for their
five bucks so sure I want you to like
fine maybe one two three links every
week on the internet of things that they
should watch or read right I think I
want you to write you know I could see
that you've got it in you so you write
you know today's learning is about
character creation today's learning is
about you know a writer's block today's
you know what I mean and then and then
and then maybe on your third live stream
that you do for two hours every two
weeks on the third one which is a month
that happen
maybe you bring in somebody who's a real
friend of yours who's highly
accomplished or or or like you know
somebody you admire and I I think when I
hear five bucks a month from somebody
that's got it like that I see a real
business okay okay back says to your
email right now sure sometimes it might
be helpful for other people listening to
as long as we're doing that is dealing
what I don't like the term impostor
syndrome personally but that's a
shorthand that everybody understands
does everyone again like oh you did this
and you did that like yeah but I still
think I suck though what what do we what
do we do with that you know what I'm
saying we go to therapy so that we can
[ __ ] our mom or dad into our heads and
then move on with our lives
that that's insecurity you know and
that's somebody that's DNA or 24 so far
very nice gonna start you know that's
that's insecurity that was put inside of
you the results are too obvious
you're kind energy is too obvious you
need to [ __ ] cut that cancer out of
your body that's [ __ ] you're clearly
not an impostor you clearly got it 24
people are interested in you right now
or interested in helping you a lot of
them are captivated by this video right
now and as I transition to the next
person they're going to email you and so
I'm as I transition here I'm gonna
literally
tweet out your email to help everybody
make it faster so I wish you well
brother you've got this this is layup
City thanks Gary I appreciate surround I
appreciate you back brother have a great
day all right give me one second Dustin
Justin what was this what was his last
name you know I pronounce it
Ellie Vee n V V V EE n yeah Ellie b een
yeah correct yeah people are really
really into Tom like I'll be honest with
you I might pay I might sign up for it
right it was like like I might want rah
got to do it like you know how much
we're into character creation like like
I think so many people can invent a
little character that they've been
doodling their whole life right a little
learn how to write a little bit of an
origin story post like crazy on
Instagram and then like literally you
know weirdly build up a following and
then minimally have a $25,000 a year
merchandise business hoodie hat t-shirt
I don't think people get it and then god
forbid somebody from hollywood sees it
and [ __ ] turns it into a netflix
animated show like people don't get it
man life is amazing when you [ __ ]
take it by the [ __ ] throat hello hey
Gary
oh one second oh okay noise are we doing
the Jodi Jodi okay good I didn't think
that was your how do you think that was
your voice Jodi so I am super well so I
have a wildly specific question about a
dilemma that I'm currently facing in my
business been a background so I'm a
fashion designer and I've been actively
developing my electric streetwear label
for about three and a half years before
becoming a official LLC in January it's
called gnarly okay and they are Li la
high design unisex reversible knitwear
produced in a highly sustainable manner
that's virtually zero waste using 3d
technology I plan to launch for public
sale next month but coronavirus that
only chase my production from China to
Italy and now
la in Brooklyn and actually this halt is
really good because it's kind of forced
me to stop and think twice about
production I'm at a point where I need
to decide whether to continue with my
original plan of starting with flat
knitwear make money and then transition
into 3d knitwear or skip the flat
knitting and jump right into 3d knitwear
because flat meeting production has
ended up being a lot more expensive than
I anticipated and it's only about twenty
to thirty five percent less than 3d
knitting I'm falling so isn't 3d
knitting a big part of the gnarly brand
story because it's like the first thing
that came out of your mouth yeah yeah
that's well that's your [ __ ] answer
okay people I make finance people make
financial decisions all the time that
compromise the story okay now that makes
sense because when I was first going
into it's a lot more easier and
accessible to do the flat knitting first
but and especially when people Jody
people pick ease people pick faster
people pick more money over the story
right right okay cool really gnarly with
a case story is the 3d part right you
were compromising it for convenience
right which a lot of I was reaching out
to 3d manufacturers and on demand
manufacturing for a while and because
I'm the small start-up and you know I
look young there's a lot of rejection
cynicism yeah yeah sure you'd only ask a
question how many there how many what
how many did you reach out to for but
there's only like four that are within
my reach in America understand I respect
though it's yeah
so it cuz 3d knitting I mean it's like
super small there's only trimming one
manufacturer technically of that machine
so okay thank you
are you gonna be are you gonna be able
to get them to do it though yeah I mean
yes
see ya because after I actually had
someone reach out to me back again one
of the people that rejected me last year
and now as they saw kind of attraction
that it's getting with my branding
they're kind of more interested and so I
have a feeling that if I really really
push it I can get it to have them but I
do really need to push it and be able to
sell that story and it is a lot more if
you consider pre selling product yes I
yeah I have completely but the problem
is I need to be able to hunt that
manufacturer down and do what I need you
and the way listen don't don't fear
pre-selling if you know don't fear it
because if God forbid you can't make it
you can return the money and and do
something nice because you weren't able
to deliver sure sure right so like all
of a sudden god forbid you can't maybe
you send back the money and some you
design a little handkerchief by hand and
send it to them do you see what I mean
so yeah fear don't fear it do you think
it's a good idea to because my idea of
doing this pre-selling Kickstarter
campaign was to do it directly straight
through my official web site rather than
doing something through like a
Kickstarter like I like that yeah I
think you could do it on [ __ ] you
could do it on [ __ ] Instagram and
post a photo of it of the design of one
that you've made and and absolutely
crushed that way - okay cool I mean I
call that I call that ghetto Kickstarter
you just post it on Instagram and say
DMA if you want it we're straight up you
know what I mean it also builds
community that way sure sure sure
can I also throw in another question
that real quick what kind of advice
would you have for someone that has a
little easier business experience and as
a designer artist background yeah
there's two things one you bring
in a business partner and you actually
give her or him a percentage of the
business or two you realize that Tommy
Hilfiger and and Tom Ford and many
others didn't have it either and [ __ ]
figured it out over time cool Michael
Kors figured it out along the way right
did you did you have any entrepreneurial
skills as a kid like sell a blow pop
have lemonade like is it in you at all
do you think I mean I I'm from from the
time I was out of the womb I mean I've
known I was gonna be a fashion designer
and that like a bride's that moves me
but as I kind of like went through si T
and my graduate studies it has been my
the way I design is a lot about
marketability and sale ability in my
design it's not about our TV [ __ ] no oh
I am I am NOT an entrepreneur but I have
a business sense you have a commercial
capability
exactly exactly because I recognize the
hope hopefully you'll be in a position
where you can hire around your
weaknesses whether that's your board to
do the accounting or things that may be
sure but if you find yourself you so
young still you find yourself in two or
three years that you need to bring in a
business partner the right way you go
yeah I mean that's the absolute dream is
to be able to do that I'm like really
working sunset to sunrise never never
never never compromise your story you
got very lucky that this pandemic
happened because it gave you another
chance to not compromise sure right I
appreciate that very much
awesome have a good day you too it's a
really good tea session I really really
like it Paul hutchinson building you
Sharon David Alexander always Sharon
Eastern he gets a follow I'm number six
five six from a manly out in top cliff
England I appreciate everybody sharing
the screenshots it's really really cool
I see all the screenshots and I am
absolutely absolutely extra credit for
Facebook links cuz I retweet those like
retweet the ones that are putting the
Facebook live links Derek Morgan and
Dean Carver just got some new audience
Oh a LinkedIn link gotta give Charlie a
little tweet there something else is
happening here all right Dustin what's
going on get a little delay no I'm just
waiting on you oh I'm ready to go thank
you so much I'm ready go cool you know
what's good Gary way from Connecticut
awesome
what can I help you with so I'm a junior
in high school right now and obviously
we're having all the junior planning and
all that right now it's online now too
so yeah so I don't think I want to go to
college and I know you don't have like a
positive or negative view on college
necessarily I have a self-awareness view
like it is for some it is not for others
I really hate it for people that it's
not for who collect debt that scares the
[ __ ] out of me
I love it for people that need it to get
to degree to do their passion because
they wanted to be a doctor their whole
lives so it's a it's definitely a a it's
not a one size fits all game and then I
also worry about the pressure of parents
who think it's the only way yeah my
parents don't they're not gonna make me
do anything but it's like the counselors
and all that telling me to go the
counselors have to work on Sulur yes
sorry Susan you know okay um yeah so how
I've made my money since I was young I
mean I umpired for a little bit if that
was the only job I've ever had like for
somebody and then from there I braked
yards now I do landscaping all that and
I just started a um like a virtual tour
company for realtors actually so tying
that into the whole College thing I I
always thought of it like if
I can make a certain amount of money per
month before I have to decide like that
would be the decision yeah is that a
good way to look at it's a great way to
look at it especially if you keep your
finances down and especially if your
parents are willing to let you live in
your home then you're [ __ ] set cuz you
almost need no [ __ ] money or if you
got four other buddies that are going to
like the local college or college by you
or or not college that you can crash
with so you can keep your expenses down
like I think the [ __ ] house with
four ambitious kids is like an
incredible environment right so you got
to make sure you're going into a house
with other hustlers not look the local
Community College where all the kids are
just [ __ ] like don't give a [ __ ]
about anything so your environments got
to be proper I think the other thing to
think about is I do think there's an
emergence of kids like you getting jobs
for guys and gals like me so one of the
things I've been thinking a lot about is
for example marketing is something
you'll always need so you know is it is
it better for you to work at vaynermedia
for you know 40 K a and commuting from
Connecticut two hours every day then and
learning for two or three years and then
stealing take that's stealing taking
that skill and applying it to your
business when oh by the way news alert
you're only 21 now so I've been thinking
a lot about like you know I always say
get close to the Sun I don't know if you
ever heard me say that but like go work
for the person you want to be like you
know like like for example if you like
fell in love with landscaping can you do
like a month's worth of homework and
find seven or eight guys and gals who
built the best landscaping businesses
from scratch from being a kid that mowed
a lawn and can you like cold DM them
LinkedIn them and email them and say I
want to be your apprentice I'll come and
work for [ __ ] nothing and grind for a
year but I'd like to learn and they're
in like Alabama and you're here and you
go down there for a year do you see
where I'm going it there is another
there is a different College where you
get paid to [ __ ] learn wisdom that
might take you 15 years to learn your
own way but you actually get paid to
learn that wisdom and over the course of
two or three years
yeah that makes sense you see but you
need to go work for an entrepreneur and
you need to tell that entrepreneur I'm
here I'm gonna get paid dick I'll pick
up a very little but I'm here to learn
so please can we have drinks or a coffee
once every two weeks cuz I know you're
busy and you can give me ten minutes of
wisdom and I can ask you questions of
observations can I be your assistant
dean and one of the greatest jobs in the
world is to be the admin assistant you
know to a [ __ ] women entrepreneur you
will learn so much it's uncanny admin
assistant yeah just literally be
somebody's assist if you were my
assistant you would learn more in six
[ __ ] months yeah you would learn in
Business School in your whole [ __ ]
life yeah so being the assistant of
entrepreneur might be a great job for
you at 18 where you getting paid 36:41
52 27k a year get [ __ ] working and
Google Calendar and picking up cleaners
and getting coffee but [ __ ] when
you're that close you're learning at a
level that's insane
thank you good luck thank you sit talk
to you soon talk to you soon that
assistant life I'm telling you right now
for so many of you want to be
entrepreneurs that assistant life is a
game changer if you're an organized
[ __ ] and you want to be an
entrepreneur I couldn't recommend you
more to be the assistant of somebody
instead of a [ __ ] job or going to
college
if that's what you want to be and that's
what you think you are an organized kid
with big ambition can crush it crush it
I greet brand lemo this is a on fire
session I think this is a real good
session today let's keep it going with
your mom what's up Gary like skip bro
how are you I am great I really hope
that Aiden is still on because it's it's
crazy that you started talking about
that because I'm literally a product of
what you've
in saying tell me here we go I love the
Sun to be tell me you tell me right now
tell me the story though I you garyvee
for anybody that's watching got me
kicked out of Bible College listening to
Gary Vee was it the cursing no it's not
illegal it's illegal
but um about four or five years ago I
was in Bible College studying she was
actually studying secondary education
and then everybody has to have like a
core of biblical studies y'all everybody
is basically a double major so
essentially I wanted to either be a high
school teacher or I wanted to go out and
be a youth pastor and just really have
fun with kids play games like who does
want to do that like who doesn't want to
be the guy that made for playing games
and like you know teaching kids and so
about to no year in I found just a
random video of yours and started
listening to your content and I feel
like God in life was like okay you don't
want to do what this man saying so we're
about to force you to do it and it was
right around the time where you were
talking about that whole self-evaluation
thing you know if college isn't for you
like don't run yourself in today go back
home live with your mom like go go stack
your money figure out what you're gonna
do
live it up I was hearing it but I was so
scared to dare to bed of course it takes
courage to live the life you want
you know like I'm 18 years old I just
moved from Milwaukee Wisconsin to
Chicago Illinois you know so I'm in this
big city our college is literally smack
dab downtown Chicago so I'm like go back
home like I just like it took enough
courage for me to leave home to get here
like what my going back to [ __ ]
Milwaukee you know and I will never
forget getting a call one day from the
school like hey you gotta go I was like
what they're like yeah you gotta go
basically my parents you know with their
nasty divorce they agreed to paying for
because the the school didn't take
certain loans so and it wasn't expensive
it was a tuition free school but she
paid for room and board and you're
supposed to pay out of pocket they
agreed to paying for that but it became
kind of like a rift in the divorce thing
I got a call
nothing so they call me in their life
hey I'm back I'm like what do you mean
okay you can't come back my mom's like
just come home I'm like no I'm not gonna
come home basically I was homeless for
six months slap on people's couches
couch hopped from place to place
literally when the school year started
back one of my old friends his roommate
never came so I literally squatted in
his room and and and snuck around the
campus because I still have my old ID
and literally I found a job where I got
a job as a call center worker and that
gave me enough money to find my own
place kind of get on my own feet I found
a a church that at that time was super
it was on the rise because they were
using periscope at that time and
periscope just shocked him up and I
found them via periscope all story short
man got offered 200 bucks to be the
intern for the senior pastor CEO he's
not just a pastor like he's a
businessman he has multiple different
businesses all the good stuff two
hundred bucks a month to do a freaking
full-time job and I did it I did it
while still working in that call center
I was in the cost and her answering
phones and like responding to emails
like scheduling meetings writing or
taking all number and you want a meeting
yeah okay give me one second okay let me
finish you hold on one second hold on
one second for everybody who's listening
because every time I bring up the take
the 28k to be the admin take the part
okay to be the admin this [ __ ]
was making 200 bucks a date like please
like like people are so entitled people
are so soft if you want your dream it
should be hard like I had a big dream of
course it was [ __ ] difficult yeah I
did that go through I did that for three
years so I say it one more time for the
people in the back sitting here how long
did that for three years three years I
get it when the the the crazy so I I did
the internship lasted for about six
months and then they came to me and
they're like hey you know do you want to
do this full-time I was like oh yeah
this is about
great like I don't have to work at the
call center yeah cool and I was thinking
like I'm gonna get offered at least this
what does that pay I get paid at the
closet but it's a church no like you
know and so I literally got offered
$27,000 to come work full-time at this
church as a personal assistant and I did
it man and I did it for for like I said
three years and um a year and a half ago
I got a phone call from my boss and he
randomly out of nowhere was like hey do
you want to be our next youth pastor
which is what I went to school for it's
literally what I was going to school for
it got kicked out of school studying to
become you know this this this guy that
could just spend his his time dealing
with teenagers and helping kids and now
we're actually one of the largest
churches here in Chicago and I have four
hundred kids that I'm responsible for
and I was able to see it because I
wasn't afraid to go so an Aidan still
watching man don't be afraid don't be
afraid to you tomorrow I'm really proud
of you I admire you Thank You Jerry
thank you so much it goes into my my
question though cuz I mean you when I
watch these I was watching yesterday I
got my TMI and my little Christmas let's
go um but when I'm watching you know I
think I hear the same like questions in
and I know that you just get you get it
out there and but I'm one of those
people as you can see with the story I
love my 9 to 5 you know so I want to get
better at that in so I got told you out
I have 400 kids alone teenagers alone
but I'm responsible for plus their
parents that look to me for advice and
guidance married be married for about
generations now and me my wife don't
even have kids yeah but I have parents
coming to me for like parenting advice
and course and then I have team members
who are all like different types of ages
I'm 23 what advice would you give for
leading that many had a couple things
you know you were built for it at 23 I
was ready to
CEO - if kovat happened when I was 23 I
would have let it I let it during 9/11
when I was 25 like you know what I would
say to you was a couple things one
you're gonna continue to live this life
like some some [ __ ] has just written do
you know what I mean
so a I actually think the single biggest
ingredient for you to be successful in
communicating to these different
constituents is humility you're gonna
it's very easy to get high on your own
supply right you're getting all this
admiration attention if you're humbled
by it and thus you actually have to
deploy humility so when you talk to mr.
and mrs. Thompson you say listen first
of all mr. mrs. Thompson I don't have
children and I admire you so much so
this comes with no judgment what I'm
seeing from little Ricky is this you
know I'm closer to little Ricky's age
than I am to yours you know and I can
associate with him some stuff I've seen
it like and I overheard a conversation
that he was having with Linda and so
what you might want to consider this is
where the humility comes in you see
where I'm going
you start the combo with the hedge what
you might want to consider and I think
in that humility you'll find that
balance that you'll be able to reach
more people because of it because at
some level what ends up happening to the
23 year old Jamal the 23 year old Gary
the 23 year olds that are watching right
now that also kind of have it like that
is you can get real caught up real quick
and all of a sudden you're coming across
audacious instead of coming across with
humility humility my man is the most
important ingredients and the gift of
communicating with the hedge even what I
do now at 44 which is like hey and I'll
say it right now one more time for
anybody who's never heard it I come
across with conviction cuz I have
conviction which can come across as
overconfident condescending I get it but
let me say it one time right now for
everybody these are my opinions and
hypotheses these are this is what I see
in business and parenting in the world
there are my opinions there they're my
observations they are my hypotheses I
don't think I'm right I don't think I'm
better I just think that this is
experience I stay in a very narrow lane
and this is my hypothesis and
observation and I think when people can
sense that that humility they're more
open to the constructive criticism or
the strategy jabong at this gifted of a
young age where people are looking to
you humility is your most important ally
yeah for sure
and I I got one more question just
because I know you talked about it a lot
so you've kind of I mean you've got any
right so many different times with
Twitter Facebook Instagram you yeah I
think he's like pre said so maybe
everything so I think your next one is
really like tick tock that you've really
been talking about a lot I'm more of a
you know get on top type of guy
motivator I have a person tick tock
okay I'm crying three point three
million followers on tick tock doing
that since I yeah okay cuz I know like
when I get I don't need to dance my kids
are all like come on let me give you a
history lesson all these platforms
become all kinds of content they start
off you know what Instagram started
office photography nerds yeah yeah yeah
true [ __ ] sunsets with a [ __ ]
filter right we're all right Facebook
was college talk hooking up well you
know Twitter was tech nerds yeah they
all started something and they all
evolved to everything got you thanks so
much Gary good [ __ ] with your mom what a
[ __ ] team with Gary Vee episode I
don't know if everybody's feeling it
I am super feeling it let me go - Thank
You Dustin for giving me a few seconds
here let me go to the let me go to the
let's see what's going on just wrote to
Tom with a cooperation proposal for a
platform that'd be very helpful
thank you John here's the quota day
people pick the easy faster and money
over tell the story that's true Anthony
I appreciate the people that are putting
out the quotes I appreciate the people
that are putting out the links think to
Facebook now Thank You Josh Jensen
giving Jamal some love you get a follow
for that John Watertown New York I
appreciate that
Josh Jenson if you drink wine I need you
on wine texts couple I haven't done the
wine tex.com plug yet that I promised my
dad every morning if you're watching
right now and you buy wine at the shitty
[ __ ] supermarket or a liquor store or
even a Total Wine BevMo the single best
way to buy wine in the world is wine
text calm
besides empathy winds knocking on my
winery the best way to buy wine in the
world is wine text calm you get a text
where the ridiculous deals that Groupon
back in the day 60 I think today's wine
is a $65 Cabernet for 29 bucks
like there's stupid deals and then you
just reply with two three four or five
bottles you just literally probably the
number it would mean the world to me and
don't actually cost money to send a text
so don't just sign up to make me feel
happy because that we don't need it if
you don't buy wine but if you buy wine
and definitely if you [ __ ] if you
shop at wine calm [ __ ]
if you're a wine calm buyer and you
don't sign up for wine text calm right
now I'm done with you
we're gonna find your IP we're gonna
block you from T [ __ ] with garyvee
you're gonna break my little [ __ ]
heart if you [ __ ] shop wine calm and
you are not your wine sold out or last
bottle if you were not a wine text right
now you broke my [ __ ] heart tell me
if you signed up for wine text right now
on Twitter so I can follow you if you
actually signed up for wine text right
now let me know
show me the screen it shows the cops
confirmation some states are not allowed
no Texas no Chicago Illinois excuse me
so there's that it doesn't let's keep
going
yeah Jamal was a great guest yeah thank
you PNG Cody Gary that's good dude you
gotta get on board with the wine text
man I got two cases of the all three
coming in today you know what you know
it is the white X thing is so crazy
because we are selling like $70 wines
for 30 or $25 wines for nine and the
shipping from New Jersey we're still you
know we're a national player but we're
still like we don't have a warehouse
Kalli or somewhere else where we can
mitigate the shipping costs like we're
just we just lose [ __ ] ungodly
amounts of money every time we shipped
to Alaska so we had to take it off for
now but we are working on a Cody and big
load you and everybody in Alaska and
thank you for supporting empathy we're
really really proud of it
man this is so excited me you dude I see
you've got the end I see you got the
admit one post on the back there yeah
dude
so I'm from Anchorage movies are my life
Gary I a little bit of context grew up
here I left to go to film school back in
2010 and I've managed to do my
internship back here in town when I
worked on Nick Cage movie called frozen
ground the stars aligned my grandmother
who introduced me to film and got me
hooked on James Bond I got to see her
say about her when she passed away and I
got to work on this incredible movie set
but I love movies Gary I've been writing
movies now for several years now I feel
like when I've been paying off I went
from a hundred and ten kid debt down to
after my next payment processes I'm down
to 39 living at home I've been living at
home for seven years
grinding away work I've been writing
I'm live-action my best friend from film
school he's animation about to a year
and a half two years ago I pivoted and
all the emerging streaming platforms I
think we think together that it's better
to break into kids animated content so
I've been writing my live-action
features I've been helping him we've
been writing kids TV shows together and
story is king if you don't have drama
you don't have [ __ ] but I obsess about
everything with film utilizing camera
tricks to push certain emotions
depending on what's happening in the
shot I love new
and how music can score goes with the
story
I think about the color palettes I think
about everything I just obsess about
film
I love film at movies so much but my big
question to you is how do i leverage my
tick-tock and my LinkedIn posts so we
can have more leverage when approaching
the bigger streaming platforms we
actually just got another rejection from
CBS right calm because my buddy he went
to the kids screen summit down in
Florida last month and he was pitching
our ideas to tons of different companies
and it's a great feeling to know that
Netflix Disney Nickelodeon Amazon all
these places are reading stuff I've read
right now but I just need help with
finding leverage for when we approach
those companies leverage comes to
character ideation and creation and then
really building it through development
and getting people to give a [ __ ] I
would tell you to get your best bud from
film school the animator I think you
need to create Instagram accounts and
tick tock accounts and Twitter accounts
for the actual gumballs great then Cody
your passion is so uncomfortably
exciting and Kovan has given me a few
more minutes here and there than normal
so I want you to send me an email to
Gary at vaynermedia and I'm gonna look
at it tonight I want to see the
characters I want to give me all the
links let me see what I can do Thanks I
also I also have pretty significant
relationships at all the screaming
companies and if I can get excited about
something I might be able to move you up
the ladder dramatically too from the
levels that you've been kind of add at
this point I really appreciate it you
know it's it's a long hard grind and I
did take top post Cody yeah seven years
it's core turn in three I want you to
read today just for fun
I want you to
he'd google it I want you to read an
article about Vera Wang around Colonel
Sanders and a guy by the name of Sydney
Frank who created Grey Goose when he was
81 years old I think your passion is so
uncommon I'm sure right now on Twitter
everyone's like a [ __ ] look this guy
Cody you know like your passion so clear
it's so endearing if I just want to make
sure that you realize that it's super
early and I have a feeling that you're
so passionate about this that if you
lived at home for another 21 years but
that film was finally made that you
would be fulfilled and I think you have
to wrap your head around that it just
changes everything if you can go there
but do me a favor Cody I'm gonna say it
again slow pirouette this is a this is a
if I'm gonna help you and look at these
characters tonight and and introduce you
some people in Netflix and Amazon I need
you to be rowing and you got to find
like the article for the yep Colonel
Sanders the Kentucky Fried Chicken dude
and a guy by the name of Sidney Frank I
think it was sy and de Y but I could be
wrong but Sidney Frank he actually
created Jagermeister so he had a success
in his 50s I think it was but 81 he
always wanted the big one and it was
gray goose and really that's what he
made it so I want you to like read
articles about them they're their little
autobiographies or whatever just I want
that to go into your [ __ ] head the
same way that James Bond did because I
think it's an ingredient that can take
you and and and be a foundational
ingredient kind of like James Bond and
grandma were the steak and I think
listening to stories about these people
is the lobster and I want you to kind of
surf and turf your life you'd a little
bit I want that element and then I will
take a look and before the end of next
couple weeks you'll hear from me and let
me see I'll give you some feedback and
I'm sure my team is watching this right
now I know d-roc you know there's I'm
proudly excited as well so some of them
may jump in I really appreciate it Gary
all right Cody Cody and the title put
like I'm the I'm the film dude for
market from Alaska and then I'll make
sure I don't lose it yeah I wish you
well talk to you thank you you're
welcome very much
bringing it yep I know there's gonna be
some tweets about Cody let's see there
we go
Kenobi on the is now part of wine tech
side like that's Queen like that's green
I know no Texas blaze Pittman I'm sorry
see what's going on here
I am on fire crystal appreciate that I
was hoping for a couple more signups
there we go
John Gould is in the billing appreciate
you signing up see who else is here Josh
Ali oh just signed up off the st. my guy
I'm worried ship to this is an Ontario
I'm not sure that's Nick what's good
really well I've been following you for
like four years now so this is like
thank you so much well I'm just gonna
give you a little context so in high
school I was buying reselling candy
mowing grass just doing stuff like that
entrepreneur I started buying and
flipping stuff so I selling buying
started clicking on eBay and I said you
see numbers like I said you see one two
thousand and I started to flip phones so
that's what really made it take off and
I started to do like 10k a month and it
was just like a big milestone for me
like 10k like so much yeah that's real
how much the thought that we make how
much profit were you making on that 10k
30% so I remember my bank account like
it went for money 2002 like five so it
was about 30% like 3000 profit so I was
planning on like move into a bigger city
and move in with my sisters and stuff
like that and growing stuff like that
but I met this guy so this is pretty
much my what I met this guy and he was a
total like opposite of me like he's a
extrovert I'm really more of an
introvert so it just really worked and
you know we teamed up and we started
econ so now we're doing Amazon
Viejo so we started EECOM and now the
last 30 days we're doing around 30k but
what are you selling
huh what are you selling so we sell
we're really big in a video game niche
we buy closeouts so we buy from
distributors and small brands and bigger
to sugar just stuff like that I like it
you don't stop my question is I'm trying
to put this in a positive way I don't
make I don't want to make this negative
but my question is it's not negative bro
it's just it's just it's your life there
is no negative or positive just ask the
question so we've been bumping heads a
lot last year but we're kind of like on
a standard ground right now but it
doesn't feel genuine it just feels like
we're working together because we've
really been any money yeah yeah what's
the what's the what's the biggest grind
between you two more it's probably more
so about he has different standard he
just wants you know he's about the money
he's about the money at all costs yeah
pretty much makes sense extroverts you
know this is what makes me a little
unique I'm wildly extroverted I'm that
guy the reason a lot of people at first
I don't know how you felt when you first
saw me but a lot of people up first like
a lot like 20% I would say people when
they first see a video of mine are like
this guy's full of [ __ ]
you know what I mean cuz I've got that
gift of gab and you got to be a little
bit cautious if that's your DNA a lot of
people that have that extroverted
mentality unfortunately often not always
also have you know that kind of like
non-ethical like when it all costs like
[ __ ] everybody who gives a [ __ ] don't
return their money you know like just
some of that [ __ ] that's common so do
you feel like that's a little bit of
like he's got that kind of thing and
where you're like a little bit more on
the straight and straight yeah and it
just feels like all this superior type
thing like everything's a competition
and it's just like sometimes I just like
he thinks to myself because I don't want
to share about it he's because he's like
because he's like well I did this and it
did better than what you did kind of
thing yeah a little bit but it also
feels like you know last year we did a
hundred and thirty two thousand in it
for the most part it just feels like I
did everything so it's just like because
I'm a computer guy so what emails
anything I'm on top of it like stuff
like that any small fires that happen in
the business I'm always putting them out
just a your operate your your the
operational part basic yeah so what's he
bring to the table um the people that he
brings into our business like more so
like connections with other big Amazon
sellers and we get inside stuff and it's
just we get a lot I get a lot of ideas
and stuff like that and who finds the
who finds the product I do this is a
tricky one here's what I would say like
any relationship communications the only
thing that works and when you stop
communicating and to your point it's on
some fake [ __ ] it's always vulnerable
and eventually it's gonna die so I think
you know and by being an introvert
introvert in might be hard for you to
step up and like call for that dinner
once this college it's done or you might
be together I don't know they like you
know call for that dinner and just
really talk it out and be like yo this
is mutually beneficial financially but
might not be mutually beneficial
psychology wise and Happiness wise and
probably ultimately then won't be that
beneficial financially can we talk this
through and maybe it's just on some like
we got to share with each other [ __ ] or
should we just split up and move on and
we'll both be happier and this was a
great chapter and we got love for each
other and like let's go that is that is
the answer the last thing is do you
think that I'm foolish so so in December
we all my business parties we flew to LA
we rented out a pit house and we rented
out exotics and took branding pictures
so I don't know I so it looked like you
guys were flossing more than you were
yeah you know I mean listen you you've
been listening to me for four years you
know the answer you know I hate that
[ __ ] more than anything
yeah so it just I came home and [ __ ]
you up yeah now you said you said all us
business partners so you got other
business partners besides dude yeah I
just want whatever he brings a lot of
money to the table look it sounds like
those guys potentially and I don't
overly judge but based on the picture
you're painting they like the idea of
the entrepreneurial lifestyle and and
back to saying other Amazon leaders like
they may be caught up in the game and
want to be the other cool Amazon
resellers and the entrepreneurs they see
on [ __ ] Instagram you know the
bizarro reversed versions of me that
think you know like the model like the
bottle like the Jets like the [ __ ]
exotics attendants like it just doesn't
sound like you're about that Nick this
situation is not long-term for you and
that's okay too like you know sometimes
a girlfriend sometimes a job sometimes a
hobby is a moment in time it's a
stepping stone to the next thing I think
what you need to do is try to end it
graciously and I think the way you do
that is by having an authentic
conversation okay
and that's hard I have not been great at
that in my career at times so I I'm
giving you advice that's hard for me
it's easier for others but you know my
dad's good at it I'll shoot it my
brother's good at it I'm not great at it
like it's tough to have the courage to
be like yo John let's have this talk I'm
not about that same leg like I'm not
sure if this is long term
can we talk this out I don't like this I
don't like this I don't like this that
comes hard for me but I know it's the
answer for you and hopefully you can do
it yeah yeah I'm just weak on a personal
level like they have come to me on
personal stuff and I really like help
them out so it's like I do care for them
and I'm always shining light and that's
what I'm saying I'm saying it doesn't
happen like too many people think when a
partnership isn't good anymore that has
to burn to the ground and be on some
lawyer [ __ ] and anger [ __ ] and [ __ ]
forever no talking [ __ ] it can be good
okay and if they think they're the magic
and like of it all they they may think
or he may think that well this is good I
can find some other person to handle the
emails of the shipping like a lot of
times the charismatic one thinks the
operations one is replaceable all right
good luck my man have that conversation
have it have it I will please we watch
this video and over and over until you
can do you think you can do it do you
think you can have the real real real
real talk you can think you got that in
you yeah we we had talks before and
that's why I'm saying like it we are on
common ground
but it's more so where you kind of like
using each other right now and every
time every phone call just like you know
about the business and we're always like
trying to get stuff done stuff like that
but just like at the same time I love
that I love you I love you for like
knowing that's what you need and so like
go go take a step back financially and
take two steps forward five steps
forward happy wise and then financially
okay all right thank you take care
yourself it's a good one man
and we're just over halfway [ __ ] do you
guys understand goodness [ __ ] show is
like do we love this show like do you
guys love this [ __ ] show [ __ ] man
like like I feel like tea with Gary Vee
like takes a big [ __ ] on the askgaryvee
show Dustin yeah I agree
I don't like now I miss India and Steve
and like all the jokes and the
entertainment value but from like a this
is like like I tend to bring
entertainment and information this you
know it's kind like 50/50 or 60/40 this
one feels like 90 [ __ ] like just
steak yeah I agree
and it's just definitely more context
and going back and yes clears I'm not
I'm not rushed
which gives me you know yeah yeah love
it
let's keep it going big shout out to
Eric Hauck Rijn for sharing the show
Grand Rapids Michigan you just got to
follow if you want to get on it actually
hold on one second give me one second
sure shoot but I'll be right there I'll
be right there
then changing the background to normal
be right with you Marley do you want to
get so follows here it is share the
screenshot and the link to Facebook or
LinkedIn and we will give you some love
Josh
Ali you so much Marley
hey Jerry thank you so much for taking
in my question today happy to do it
so just a little bit of xre about me on
the fist Tennessee and a corporate event
planner and as you can imagine with the
Kevin 19 mi kid has really hit as hard
lucky for us we don't only do in-person
events we also do fulfillment and kits
and shipping and then we also do in
sourcing for premium items and then also
we do live or virtual events so we're
really just trying to figure out what is
the narrative of like okay we still
obviously want to do in-person events
after this but to get us through this
time right now and just not knowing when
it's gonna be over how we overcome this
barrier right now
that's where we're really at I'm just
trying to convert those you need to
build brand right now for prospective
clients when it's when you're on the
other side I mean this is real [ __ ] like
you know my you know I've lost seven
figures and public speaking and
performance events you know and it's not
coming back
like and so what am i doing I'm
continuing to put out content and
continue to build friends so when we get
on the other side of it you know some
things you know they've been using a lot
of war terminology on mainstream media
and things that nature there's some
truth to that right like there was
businesses and hey this was night if
this was 1940s and World War two is like
starting to pop off and you're asking me
like how do you get through this when
all the boys and the company just went
off to Europe the answer is you don't
like sometimes the answer is you don't
and I think the one move we all have
Marley is to build brand so QA shows
LinkedIn white papers 16 tips to how to
become a great public speaker that gets
paid as a LinkedIn post maybe a good
idea right like things that company for
tips that a company should think about
when they when they put on an event you
know like like like just information
acting like an editorial machine is
probably is the way right now because
you know really storytelling and and
valuable information is the only thing
you can do right now because other than
other than put on an operator as many
virtual
because the reality is this is where we
are yeah ISIL and so when you're talking
about going out and like being the
subject matter expert and talk like
compelling telling stories right now
what platform do you think is the best
to you that or do it on all platforms
all of them too many people want to pick
the right platform like for you honestly
like LinkedIn is a monster it's a
monster and so I think LinkedIn is
something you have to get your company
has to get great at three four five six
pieces of content a day on LinkedIn is
something that I would recommend okay
I'm so in like you know like I'm talking
yeah but it's gonna toriel right it's
not promotion too many people go into
infomercial and I want them to go into
you know New York Times I want them to
go into Consumer Reports I want them to
go into the Wine Spectator I want them
to bring value so notice how my examples
were for the audience not for the sales
funnel for your business absolutely so I
guess with my business it's more of like
you know we're creative industry and
like we're paid a lot of times when our
ideas how you like kind of go between
giving away all your ideas and then
still drink a brand for yourself okay
Marley I give away more my ideas the
world is abundant you giving out your
ideas gonna lead to the customer is some
other Marley and Texas gonna take that
and run with it yes
it's not coming out of your pocket it's
the greatest confusion of all time the
world is abundant and your best ideas
lead to business not lead to somebody
stealing it and losing business it's the
greatest confusion in the business world
okay make that awesome absolutely every
day thank you so much Gary agree hate it
have a great day Moses James James you
gotta follow my guy I am her 378
follower you were in Nigeria I got a lot
of love but he entrepreneurship in that
world let's do it let's do it let's do
it appreciate it's them and Stephan
Bonnar need chase Kevin what's going on
Gary
and I could not even sleep last night
know what I was gonna talk with you man
you've changed my life thank you bro how
so so about five months ago my buddy
Brandon and I we started up a tick-tock
called fantasy freaks I'm reppin the
shirt right now and we talked fantasy
football and pretty much football in
general and at the time it was like okay
who's on tick-tock pretty much comedy
videos dance videos and Gary Vee so it's
kind of it was pretty scary to start
just posting about fantasy football
something we're super passionate about
and we decided we liked it you did it
because I was pushing pushing pushing
you I mean you were just saying okay do
it I was like okay [ __ ] it let's just go
let's just so we spent our I'm the
freshman in college from Columbus Ohio
and I was like alright we're gonna spend
our Friday nights making 16 NFL break
down videos for every game for posting
16 video straight just I mean it takes
three hours four hours we're like all
right let's just do it so we did it we
were kind of grinding we've seen a lot
of linear growth we're up to two hundred
thirty thousand followers right now on
tick tock and it's literally all because
of youth saying you can take your
passion and turn it into tick tock
success and you can grow on social media
in it I can't tell you how much it's
changed my life you know it's it's so
awesome but you know we have a really
strong following pretty much a younger
demographic so like kind of like the
eight to 16 year old range yeah so I
guess my my question is is you know
we're super passionate about this it's
we'd love to have it as a career in the
future how do we take like are following
on tick tock and turn it into a
profitable business and both you're in
the best spot ever first of all you have
four more years before you have to write
you're gonna finish school yeah no rush
no rush and you you [ __ ] won your
audience is going to be of an age where
they'll be willing to buy something
right at the time like not only do you
have these next three and a half years
of college but then you also have the
fact that you're still [ __ ] 22 and
you and your buddy can go and [ __ ]
you know where I'm about to go room with
[ __ ] three other knuckleheads [ __ ]
eat McDonald's all day and be [ __ ]
set you've probably got
what I think you should do is what I did
which is not monetize them like goat
just build the [ __ ] audience at all
costs and then in like let's have this
discussion in four years okay cuz people
are always asking like oh you guys
getting paid yet and we're like we don't
need the money like don't least I'm not
taking on any I'm not taking on any
college that I'm in no rush to make any
money and you know my audience is really
young I don't know how much money
they're even willing to spend on like a
package conversation no you are not
allowed to ask for money do not think
about $1 for four years here's why and
that's a very different answer than we
gave earlier to Tom who needs to make
five bucks right from everybody it's
because you kind of you've got the
luxury the privilege
thank God the serendipity to not which
puts you in the power position ya know
it's it's a good spot but like no no no
no it's the best and when the day comes
in four or five years there might be
[ __ ] augmented reality filters there
may be new some new piece of clothes
that we put the logo on bro we don't
know what the [ __ ] gonna happen in
four years
well I always talked to my buddy Brandon
I'm like you know even if it's not like
football if we can find the next thing
to elevate fantasy football or whatever
it is at that time we'll be able to have
a following that loves football that
loves pretty much everything about how
we're going us up to your set 100% 100%
brand building 100% brand building for
the next arena beers 100% brand building
ya know I'm I'm in no rush I don't need
the money
it's not it's not about it's about it's
about spending even a second debating it
from this moment on
just like the tick tock thing that I
pushed you know more minutes I'm more
worried about watch this how many
followers you have an Instagram so
that's the good that's the question so
we wanted to push the tick-tock first
and take advantage of that organic reach
kind of correct so erect so I mean ours
do you have an Instagram I have three
hundred and two thousand on Twitter so
that's right three hundred on Instagram
two hundred on Twitter 2000 winner but
yeah we're still growing is that
English this is where I was going notice
how I asked the question I know exactly
where you at you're a part of this new
generation that listened to me crushed
on tick-tock instead of worrying about
[ __ ] selling them some [ __ ]
[ __ ] $9.00 you know draft guide or a
[ __ ] t-shirt what I want you to do is
now add two pieces of content a day on
tick-tock that has the sole purpose to
drive people to follow you on facebook
on Instagram and Twitter
okay so Instagram Twitter thoughts on
YouTube people talk about that yeah okay
because that's a little bit because I'm
always like is it worth putting in my
time to the other social media platforms
when I could just really push this
growth on tick-tock like oh I don't know
just do it all cuz college student
balance the tick tock touts the
Instagram Twitter yep okay man like more
you have a moment in time is tick-tock
things gonna go away just like vine kind
of like it you may not have to push
other things not I don't think it's
gonna go away like vine growth you're
saying growth but the reach the reach
bro
like like you know like you already seen
it ya know
especially this past couple weeks it's
gone down you've probably seen on your
page do I have because I listen I've
been consistent about this it's a land
grab yeah and so the early people go
there is you can't be Charlie anymore
there's too many people on it you could
be honest we are versatile in our in our
niche which is like a big thing first is
great and I'm glad about two-thirty but
best always will matter in the end but
most of all listen to me and listen to
me good two pieces of counted a one for
Twitter one for LinkedIn all the ideas
all this energy that you think about how
to monetize all goes away and it all
goes into the creation of creatives that
is built for the intent to follow on
Twitter giveaways on tik-tok hey guys
for everybody that follows us on Twitter
right now and you use hashtag you know
fantasy freaks we're gonna pick two of
you randomly and go on Zune with you for
15 minutes of talk football for your fan
base that's exciting all of a sudden
you've tripled your
number on Twitter on one [ __ ]
tick-tock extra post a day it's awesome
I kit that's awesome that's I I'm gonna
grind it out I promise I'm so sleepy I
thank you much Gary you're welcome
brother [ __ ] dropping [ __ ] gems and
keys and wandering a [ __ ] you want to
call it on tea with Gary Vee I'm [ __ ]
at it today I'm feeling it about the
show Dustin is that [ __ ] don't
realize how [ __ ] smart I am edition
they just think that I'm loud and
charismatic I [ __ ] know the game
Dustin 100% I'm Yoda in this [ __ ] one
what's good I'm super excited I'm super
thankful here for this opportunity you
know talking to you yeah I'm
international so we don't have like the
axis okay you know the text community
and stuff so super super super happy my
question saying yeah and my question is
like it comes from some of the things
that you have said this past year this
past days and to keep it like contextual
and so you talked about like how it's
good not to be an expert and I really
like the thing about the journey it was
you know it kind of clicked but I feel
like that works when you have like that
cloud that goal of becoming a chef you
know so in my case you know I'm 20 22
years old
I mean I'm what I like and what I mean
my interest is in cars so cars yeah
I'm studying engineering for it to
Stefan and I consume a lot of cars and
stuff like that but I feel like I'm
young I don't have the the driving
experience
have the real work engineering
experience in the field that the people
I follow and the people I admire have so
I feel like if I were to put out content
now I would just be like rehashing there
takes like their experience takes and
will be just like doing that what one do
you know what a DJ is yeah so I think I
think of those engineers as songwriters
as rappers as artists and I think of you
right now at 22 or 20 having the ability
to be a DJ so to your point and I you're
a very smart kid for picking up on I
thought in the whole week and a half of
tea with Gary be that piece of advice I
gave about documenting the journey of
becoming the thing that you want to be
was one of the two or three best things
I said so thank you for picking up on
that I think you can do that and I think
the way you do that to your point
because when you're doing the chef you
can do it but when you're talking about
engineering it's hard to show that
because you can't quote unquote do it
instantly I think you need to think
about being a DJ I think you know I
don't know if you've seen on tick-tock
where people have a video on
green-screen like I have this background
and then they talk over it I like the
idea of you making videos or writing
articles that take something that
somebody said and then you give your
youthful
hypothesis yeah so yeah that's who that
was my thing I know I can write stuff
but I my biggest trouble is like the
value proposition you know where's the
value the value the value prop the value
proposition comes in one observation one
agreement one disagreement one have you
thought of you know I loved what Juan
Pablo said but has he thought about this
if you're right one time you win I'll
give you an example when I was a wine
kid at 16 I thought that Australian and
New Zealand wines should be bigger so I
could have wrote articles or my videos
saying I think one day Australian wines
and New Zealand wines will be bigger I
ended up being write something you write
today that ends up happening in 11 years
might be the LinkedIn article that you
wrote that gets you a job or a bigger
job when you're 31 and yeah I mean if
you're wrong like don't be afraid of
being wrong is good wrong is good wrong
stuck nobody's gonna stop from hiring
you for being wrong at 22
everybody's gonna hire you for being
right at 22 she makes it one last
question
from my long list yes it's a short one
it's like how do you leverage your
softness if there is a way to like you
always thought about you know this give
Jamaa from before he's worked in a call
centre for three years he's been in the
hardship I haven't you know I'm I live
with my parents but my parents they pay
for everything I'm super grateful for
that I mean my dad has worked super hard
he works from home but you know he's
been through stuff stuff stuff my mom my
mother as well but I haven't you know
good news
good good news you will unfortunately
for all of us life is hard and maybe
just because at this point you've been
very fortunate
doesn't mean eventually you will not
have hardship
you can't fake hardship but you need to
lean into is gratitude right now
right and what you can do is put
yourself in a position to you know build
on your own two feet so you could get a
job you could or or you take advantage
of this moment when it's going well and
you do do what we just talked about and
produce an ungodly amount of content
with your thoughts and dreams and
observations and ideas around other
people's work as a DJ so you know don't
beat yourself up because God that God
has put you in a spot where we don't
control who our parents are who we've
been born into and what circumstance
we've been born into on you know you
will have your hardships and that is
life and right now take advantage of it
not being as hard and and produce this
content yeah I feel like like the
hardship is in the dome
you know when you talk tough but have a
strong mentality I may be really opposed
you know I've been I have I've had like
in one way I understand you're welcome
thank you so much you're very thoughtful
kid I wish you a great future I love
this [ __ ] show tea with Gary Vee I'm
gonna [ __ ] figure out sucks when coal
beds over I would have to go back to I
have to [ __ ] hack it it's gonna you
know it's just right now we can still
make it work once we're back in the
office and stuff yeah but you know how
that [ __ ] Scott user 15,000 follower
plus nice little following I appreciate
you sharing the show brother alright
Caitlin I'm that and you're backing way
better for you oh great great
so thanks for having me on my question
is kind of an interesting one in that
I'm not in traditional entrepreneurship
I've been pretty successful in the
medical device field and have been
moving up as an executive but I struggle
with like how do you move up in that
executive field without losing
authenticity so I struggle
and then you discuss when you when you
move up in a corporation you're playing
politics it's the nature of the game up
now now you don't have to I think you
have you know there's a big difference
between a hundred percent transparent
authenticity and and you know really
compromising who you are in your soul
right okay so so biting your tongue is
something that in life is just normal
and entrepreneurship land or corporation
doing something that compromises who you
know doing something that undermines
somebody that you think is competing
with you for the job that's only
available to you or her or you and him
and like like sabotaging them you know
that's compromising who you are right
say you know so you know bad talking
about a competitive employee that's
trying to move up to that might be
compromising who you are you know
selling something you don't believe in
there's a problem right that's
compromising who you are so like that's
how you have to navigate it right I mean
do you suggest like for someone who just
loves the process so I love the grind
like I just I love working I just get it
thank you so much do you think that it's
better to go into entrepreneurship if
you have that mentality I'm not a surly
entrepreneurship is a skill like and and
and also there's some people who just
love being a number two seven twelve
fourteen but assume is all the actual
pressure to make money is on them at all
costs and deal with koban and deal with
you know the building burning down and
the best person quitting and somebody
stealing and you know there is a stomach
that comes along with entrepreneurship
you know even when I deliver all that
stuff just watching your face I'm like
well I think she might be able to do it
like if you don't if you don't frown on
that and yes let me say this
Caitlyn you might you know just even
listening to you right now you might
just want to try it so you don't have
regret when you're 92 of like [ __ ] I
should have tried yeah because I kind of
started a side hustle it's it got pretty
six
it's like I'm trying to do two things at
once
can you afford to not have the main job
and go add something not quite yet can
you can you change your lifestyle to be
able to get there or would you prefer so
now the question becomes would you
prefer to change your lifestyle because
it's burning in your stomach and you got
to start tomorrow or could you put a
plan in for another year of going
hardcore savings that then gives you
that air cover for a year or what have
you to go after it yeah which I could I
could probably do another year I think
the hard thing is just giving up the
need to win I want to win it everything
so I think [ __ ] love it
I mean listen competition is that like
my competitive spirit is foundational to
my success you know then you should look
at your lifestyle yeah like you know
when you want something all of sudden $4
coffees all of a sudden three
subscriptions that you're paying for
that you never [ __ ] use all of a
sudden like you know a lot of men even
even the outside of like the real below
the poverty line like I've been blown
away by people that make 35 K a year
emailing me literally emailing me their
credit card bills and there are other
bills photos of it and talking about how
they figured out how to save eight
hundred bucks a month and what it did
for them like listen the audience that's
watching right now every one of us
[ __ ] is wasting money on dumb [ __ ]
that's holding us back from happiness
yeah that's true can you do your nails
can you do your nails every three weeks
instead of every week can you like can
you stop buying [ __ ] Starbucks it's
that real there's there's so many little
hacks that can lead them and by the way
for a lot of people doesn't sound like
for you thank God or for me but for a
lot of people they're in some scary
financial situations right now and they
didn't [ __ ] listen to me about saving
and not spending money on dumb [ __ ] and
now they're caught yeah yours is a
little bit more of a high-class problem
thank God cuz you've got the talent
you've worked hard which is do you want
to give up some lifestyles right now to
go right into
or do you want to have a real strategy
and like wait another year save up heavy
right between you and your lifestyle and
having the job and then go for it
I think both are incredible options
you've got time okay thank you so much
you're welcome so much getting take care
bye bye
oh boy this is really getting good my
man it's mark mark how are you are you
doing good I'm doing super well thank
you that's the first thing
secondly I have a quick question I am a
photographer as a side hustle my main
house who pays my bills and it does you
know what it needs to do for me but my
side hustle is my passion photography I
wanna I started a business maybe like a
month and a half ago and great timing
right it works out but yes my issue is
that I'm in an area I'm in Connecticut
that's for photography it's not
necessarily the most creative and also
people who are not necessarily willing
to pay as much as my services I feel my
services at work so well it's just it's
the audience is it supplying them is a
supply and demand or does it deliver
some level and demand issue yeah because
there's just so many [ __ ]
photographers like people like sure Gary
you got to pay more for all these video
creators I'm like there's 80 south
thousand of them I should be but less
like you know like so so for me what I
would I wouldn't blame the area I would
blame the supply and demand photography
is a [ __ ] up supply and demand game
there's just so many people that love it
so much
like you're [ __ ] up you know right
now somebody's listening like this
[ __ ] he's actually got a good
job he's [ __ ] me up because
photography is my life
and him doing out on the side is [ __ ]
me up you see where I'm going but for my
business I have not focused on I do
headshots and stuff like that for for
customers but I also have targeted
medical supply for medical supply
building photography so so what I've
done there is I literally take in my
skills not in the space of what's in
Connecticut but more so going on a stake
out of C and done jobs for a company
that contracts me to contract other
people so while I can still be creative
with my own photography for my business
perspective I can subcontract another
photographer which I am actually helping
with a photographer's and real quick
let's not demonize the state of [ __ ]
Connecticut
let's demonize that maybe for the
industry that you're focused on for
example if you were thinking about CPG
companies food companies you can doing
photos for brands and food you would
[ __ ] love Connecticut because
Westchester and Connecticut are loaded
yes so you see them going you know
Hennessy white is a brand and you can't
really buy it in you know in the States
but I've done some some product
photography on my own is kind of playing
posted it and was like you know I can
really do this with this as a business I
could do that that's something else but
I've never really thought about it as
okay wanna do more product product
photography stuff then really more I
just so be creative and I can still get
my [ __ ] I got a good point you demonized
the serendipity of which businesses were
in the state or the general area and
instead of realizing wait a minute I can
reverse this and deploy creativity which
is what that's the nut you that's a
scratch of trying to you know you know
yeah that that itch and so you know
there's part of if you were doing horse
photography there's parts of Connecticut
where you could roll it up I got you I
got you so just change the mindset of
what I'm looking at and not more so okay
gotcha
thank you you got it you're welcome
that's what I love about this show thank
you my man that's what I love about the
show like man
Gustin do you understand the Yoda [ __ ]
nothing like it's real man like the
answers are out there you know natural
talent experience between in this great
place I'm like I can just I see it yeah
I [ __ ] see it just need someone they
would kind of clarify it for us
sometimes yeah because I just see it
like I understand it like I can help and
I want to help when you can see it and
you want to help
it's [ __ ] game over keep this going
give me one second you can get it kind
of go oh let me just sign up for one
text calm there we go Ilana you get a
follow up thank you so much with you see
today's Cabernet opera if you love
Cabernet today's if you're a silver oak
KMS cake bread today's Cabernet offer is
out of control
Matt what's good what's up Gary
I tried I've been taking your tips
I did a post the other day that I
thought was horrible and it actually did
good that is actually I ever did so it
was like well no time for everybody Matt
one more time everybody's listening so I
play I play guitar a love song right
that's not very thing they I did this
bit on the guitar and I screwed up a
little bit I'm like I'm not gonna post
this and then and then I was like you
know what I'm just you know what start
documenting stop you know so I posted it
it's the best post it's got the most
like so I've ever had
so [ __ ] happy Matt this is this is
happening 5,000 times a day two to five
million times a day 50 billion times a
day people are overthinking this [ __ ]
thank you so much for sharing that story
you just helped 54 people watching this
yeah because you yourself can't judge
what the markets gonna think I have
nothing but humility I never think I'm
right I'm just curious what the markets
gonna say and that's why I make this
isn't about being right or being a
perfectionist or thinking I'm right this
is about me being curious what the
markets gonna say I enjoy the feedback
loop from the content more than the
content because it's for them it's not
for me everyone's selfish isn't insecure
I'm selfless and curious that's pop
that's why I was gonna ask you I started
doing some posts on us like I love
writing songs that's why I love to do
but I started doing some posts on some
tutorials the software I use those do
good you know like as an original
songwriter I it's hard like people don't
unless I have a hit song alright I don't
know people care you know and then Matt
something I've been thinking a lot about
something I've been thinking a ton about
for songwriters how many song how how
much volume of songwriting can you do
give me like a I can write three songs
in a week or usually once a month like
just just you your range your general
range I'm sure that I do like one one
piece a month but this is the thing I
was scared to release the [ __ ] I mean I
have two albums just I cannot believe
you just said this is what I'm most
excited about you ready I'm a big idea
yeah ready I've been wanting to share
this you're the man you ready I think
that I think many songwriters should
literally write songs and literally post
them for free on their Instagram account
and call it a day and let people [ __ ]
take it and actually make the song
well-liked anybody
no no I mean I want you to write a song
and literally post it on tick-tock
YouTube Facebook Instagram like the
written [ __ ] song maybe you read it
and then you say and now you all take it
I believe I believe that if you did that
eventually some incredible artist comes
along makes the song it explodes you get
nothing for it you're not getting the
residuals the royalties but it changes
the course of your career and that's
better than this [ __ ] sitting in your
head or sitting in your [ __ ] closet
it's a different twist it's a big idea I
read you it's a big idea you know I can
see somebody stumbling on it and then
[ __ ] then hiring you to write like
drink like [ __ ] the Dixie Chicks like
[ __ ] them and like I just think it's
[ __ ] real bro I think it's real
I think what's it doing in your [ __ ]
head and on your pad nothing
yeah put out there songs for free on the
internet and not be sad when one of them
hits and gets no royalty and maybe the
artist by the way you may get lucky get
a crazy up-and-coming talented artist to
do the song it crushes and they also her
a sweet soul and actually do pay you
royalties as if or set you a check or if
they didn't it still would give me the
exposure that leads to [ __ ] you know
Carrie Underwood hitting you up the next
week
yeah yeah exposure yeah what do you have
it's a lot sitting on your pad in your
head doing big [ __ ] for you there it's
doing jack [ __ ] for you under fire girl
and then your [ __ ] head it's nothing
nothing
garbage zero doesn't exist does it it's
the D ever sometimes I feel my biggest
ambition
yeah songwriting is my biggest fear do
you have I mean
skyress scared of your own dream yeah
but it's it's kind of enticing too
because it's so hard and it's so it's so
challenging that I want to do it you
know do you is that like you with the
Jets like is it like to me the Jets
thing is kind of just like something
that's been around since I was a kid
it's the process like for me if I was
you I'd be doing what I just told you to
do because I just love songwriting and I
want my songs to be heard and the idea
of me putting out on Instagram written
lyrics and [ __ ] whether it's you know
Russ or well he does ocean but like
Rihanna or [ __ ] an up-and-comer like
you think about this Billy Eilish could
have saw it three years ago sang it like
like I don't think people get it like
creativity sitting in your own [ __ ]
head and then your [ __ ] drawer ain't
doing [ __ ] for you then people get into
like oh but I don't want to be taken
advantage of I'm like you can't be
taking advantage of when nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you so how do you become
giving a [ __ ] about you put it out for
free that's what I believe in
yeah Matt do you know how many agencies
how many marketing agencies and
independent solo marketing social media
experts literally spend their life
consuming all my concept of free and
then selling it to somebody else and
maybe media doesn't get it to the tune
of hundreds of millions
I eat my own dog food Matt do me a favor
do this for me let this moment happen
post for free on tik-tok on and the way
you do it on tick-tock is maybe the
video is just a [ __ ] melody over the
paper that you wrote it on how you write
but and then like in the copy you
literally write the song on Instagram
maybe it's on how do you how do you
write you
computer do you write on pad I ran with
guitar and then and then I record it I
usually record it and is this the music
not the lyrics
both music and liqueurs I love it bro
put it out put it out for free put it
out for free maybe you end it with hey
and now you go record and you and feel
like literally you play it and then and
every time you're like this is matt w
and now you the more talented performer
than me go take this for free and make
your own version I'm telling you right
now it will change your life as a writer
I'm convinced yes yes I'm convinced
okay good luck okay god that just helped
literally somebody just watch that and
change the course of their writing
career I literally believe there's a 16
year old 15 year old Tiffany and
Milwaukee laying right now watching this
this is why I love how life actually
works this show would have never
happened it's not corona she would never
be home to watch this if it was not for
corona she just heard that literally
tiffany in Milwaukee fifteen year old
who's writing her journal who can't
perform too scared to perform who had
never been discovered who's gonna listen
for me who's gonna use that as
motivation who's gonna put it out and
[ __ ] her life is gonna change and
she's gonna be one of the great music
where there's of all time I really
believe that and I can't wait to meet
her at the Grammys in 21 years she comes
up and gives me a huge hug somebody who
I was like what and she's like team Gary
B 2020
I am hey hi Gary
how are you I believe stoked so first of
all I want to say thank you I just found
you like three months ago and I started
watching like well here's the real story
one night I was up really crying and
upset about stuff and knowing I had to
face losing my job the company shutting
down and just things and I'm not happy
with it anyway social services project
coordinator boring anyway a survival job
and so as up in the middle night two
three money flashing through to do
Facebook ads I don't know anything about
anything
and I come across Gary day and it's the
talk where you're in Jersey and you're
going this is some real [ __ ] man just
some real [ __ ] I start crying because
I'm in working now but I grew up in
Jersey I was born in Paterson grew up
and guard the other County and like I'm
like I'm sit right up in my bed I'm like
yeah oh my god this is my guy and there
was no clickfunnels that you didn't want
nothing from me you didn't want me to
pray a prayer you didn't want me to do
nothing and I'm like oh my god I love
this guy so I've been so totally
addicted
few people hate me now unlike Gary
cheerleader my daughter makes fun of me
she says Gary maniac but it's only
because I'm just beating from the well I
take notes I just listen I take it all
in and so I did this I need
self-awareness thing and I figured it
out
all these years sitting in a job I hate
I really love to write I went back into
writing a little bit and because of you
because of you Gary I got myself a
writing coach and last week oh my god
and pulled the freaking trigger and I
put an article up on LinkedIn I was so
cloudy all damn day
oh my god the world's gonna freakin
block like I listened to Gary I've been
to Toastmasters I've done some public
speaking I mean but I usually I dipped
my feet in and I back out again but
people tell me that you know you should
do this more and I kind of hide behind I
gotta pay the bills so I better do my
nine-to-five well guess what February
14th my last day so like I'm overdosing
on your stuff now Thank You Diane anyway
olders do I have to not as not as old as
you think you don't have to tell me but
I'm gonna get the news whatever [ __ ]
number you say you know I'm gonna say
you're young cuz it's true I know I know
so my question is I really I have to
change gears I wanted to change gears I
feel like I've been sitting on this fire
like a volcano all these years and I I
just feel like now's the right time I
just ask open I would have been at work
I wouldn't have been listening to you
well maybe I would have been watching
quietly on my desk my boss not knowing
but yeah she's gone now anyway I just
don't know where to go now what do you
want - what do you want to do well I
write
and I'm right actually amount like the
fifth chapter of the story of me and I
did that because you did the
self-awareness talk and I'm like I need
to tell the story so there's a lot of
pain there's a lot of tragedy there's a
lot of are you or are you able to tell
the truth are you really going there
yeah mine was very exposing and I that
other thing you said about okay if
that's what's in your way just do what's
in your way so they're all right I'm
just gonna vomit the whole [ __ ] out get
it out there and and I know do you have
a Facebook I do I do have you ever have
you ever done Facebook live no do you
feel like when you put up a LinkedIn you
get some comments oh yeah I got a lot of
feedback but a lot of people didn't put
it in the channel they put it private DM
me and I was like okay it's okay
that's okay I get that because they're
sharing with you certain things they
don't want other people to see and I'm
sure right now on Twitter and on the
Facebook live and on the LinkedIn live
people are like oh my god I love this
one like you have such an authentic kind
of like he you know it's so funny I
would have if you didn't say it earlier
at this point I would have asked you are
like you from Brooklyn or New York or
whatever you got that East Coast gal
thing I think that you could potentially
be very interesting on live were you
just talking here I think he's to do
what I do I think you listen you know
what I'm great at I'm great at being
Gary Vaynerchuk and staying in my lane
and talking about what I know and not
talking about what I don't know you
don't hear me talking about a ton of
[ __ ] because I just don't know and I
know funny and I have a funny intuitive
feeling that you just could be really
great at being Diane Melville and I
really think that you should try
Wow yeah that's I think I I think you
should go on Facebook live see who shows
up you've obviously got friends
relatives co-workers former high school
friends all that shouldn't just talk
about well I appreciate that I think I
think you should talk about still I like
stories a lot let's play a bit tell me a
funny story happy sad and different tell
me a story what high school did you go
to in Jersey Allentown in Allentown PA
no no Allentown New Jersey its central
oh I know where that wait a minute
Allentown give me the other two wait a
minute 7a on on what on the Turnpike
yeah got it
okay bye Jackson yes yes great adventure
great so give me a story from high
school anything not ideal but I was kind
of like trying to be in with the popular
kids and so I went this I can't believe
it I love you you're already
entertaining me and everybody else I'm
telling you that right keep going so I
made four basketball squad and I get all
like I'm like my friends are here I get
up there and I screw it up
I mean I'm at a sink I'm totally got no
rhythm I can't but I can't do it okay so
they all love me so much they gave me a
golden freaking megaphone and me me
honorary cheerleader like kind of like
mascot because they like you so much but
you said [ __ ] at it yeah take just kind
of like owned me you know and I was like
man that's except you know what though
that little micro story in itself as you
develop your game of talking with people
and things
Nature has so much to it because that
then becomes a lesson it becomes a
lesson of courage and not worrying about
it it becomes a lesson of like
insecurity / wanting to fit in gave you
the energy to do that it was a lesson of
compassion and kindness from the people
that took you in even though you
couldn't do it there's just a lot there
who's who was the cutest boy in high
school oh he's still mad at me his
name's Pete got conviction I appreciate
it
they have listened to me story time
stories lessons a lot of stories around
don't be like me I did a job just for
safety I was scared I was taught I don't
I don't know if this is true I'm making
some stuff up now I was taught by my
parents to just get a safe stable job
don't be like me I regret it but it's
not over yet for me so for all of you
it's not over
don't take that [ __ ] job follow your
dreams I you know I had the courage to
finally write something like I died in
your entertaining you've got like even
your sayings I'm like I didn't have it
like like you've got a little stick the
reason people told you to do more of it
is you have it in you I can see it from
a mile away oh my god I love you Carrie
I love you
listen to my brother listen to me listen
to me you have to do LinkedIn and
Facebook lives try it
okay you tik-tok tubes I see a lot of
people doing that type of stuff there
yeah listen Diane make keep going keep
going down this Gary be trained and I'm
and she you won't need it and you will
live a happy [ __ ] life I see it in
you you've got this yay all right Gary
take care I'm gonna end it with that
everybody I hope you enjoyed today's tea
with Gary Vee I thought it was the best
episode to be frank I think the cadence
is getting there I think we got through
a lot of questions I think there was a
lot of [ __ ] lessons I hope one really
hit you in your soul and now the most
important part of Tila Gary B which is
the do part right now you're inspired
right now you see the observation the
question now is will you take the energy
and I think I think the 11 - I am - noon
our of the team with Gary Vee show is
the most important part now take this
energy now take this momentum now go
[ __ ] do don't dwell do don't don't
complain create you know don't mope make
like [ __ ] this is your opportunity
please use this incredibly difficult
global pandemic tragedy for so many
unfortunately tragedy for so many of
them be grateful that you aren't losing
a loved one or you yourself are not
losing your life and go take advantage
of it go please go please go I believe
in you I believe in you a lot more than
you believe in yourself I believe in the
Internet I believe in these platforms I
believe in the opportunity I believe in
it please please use my energy to give
you the courage please use my energy to
be your confidence please use my energy
to cut out the insecurities and the bad
parenting a bad environment or
insecurity or a bad situation this R
suffix it's not [ __ ] shot please I
love you Dustin thank you for being on
the ones and twos I'll see everybody
tomorrow 9:00 a.m. Eastern please share
this take a screenshot now please share
this please get your friends you know
get a text group get a whatsapp group
get your post this on your Facebook
group let's get people watching this
show
it's [ __ ] doing good I can feel in my
[ __ ] bones
[Music]